ich habe heute einen Iftar ausgerichtet
für Mark Gebauer von A bis Z alles was
das Herz begehrt ich hoffe es hat dir
geschmeckt sodass noch nicht sagen wir
sehen jetzt wie das Ganze zubereitet
wurde und zwar einiges an Zutaten
Lammschulter Harissa ganz viele
verschiedene Zutaten die ich jetzt nach
und nach in meinen Bräter geben werde
einmal kräftig anröste und dann im Ofen
butterweich ziehen das ist ein
orientalisches Gericht marc hat gar
nicht speziell nach was orientalischen
verlangt du kannst zwar öfter natürlich
essen brauchst du Lust hast aber ich
wollte es für meine experience für mein
Gefühl so auch für euch so ein bisschen
traditionell halten deshalb gibt es
geschmorte Lammschulter mit tadikreis
also quasi mit Safran Reis mit einer
schönen Kruste oben drauf ich selbst
freue mich sehr darauf fangen wir an
ganz wichtig natürlich das Fleisch ist
auch alleine also wir haben es beim
Hallein Metzger geholt ich gebe das hier
einmal in eine Schüssel wo ich ein
bisschen marinieren werde ich massiere
das jetzt ein bisschen ein Harissa so
eine Paprika Chili Paste dieser Klaus
grillt 10 Stunden normal oder 15 Minuten
einkleben dann machen wir das mal im
Mittelpunkt unserer Zubereitung steht
Bräter hier der hat ein richtig schönen
dicken gusseisern Boden und
transportiert damit perfekt die Hitze
sollen wir immer ungefähr gleich
bleibende Hitze und genau das brauchen
wir um unsere Lammschulter richtig schön
zart sogar noch ein bisschen Zeit aber
die haben wir auf jeden Fall weil wir
essen heute Abend vom Aufwand her
abseits der Zeit super einfaches Gericht
wir nehmen ein bisschen Öl geben das in
den Bräter der Topf ist heiß das Fleisch
ist mariniert wir geben das jetzt hinein
und Braten ist schön an ordentlich
Restaurant dran bekommen von allen
Seiten denn das gibt uns Geschmack jetzt
steigt auch schon das wird Mark gefallen
so eine leichte Schärfe durch die
Harissa in die Luft das Zeug hat auf
jeden Fall in sich aber ich glaube mag
lieber was Schärfe angeht nicht so
leicht aus der Ruhe wenn das ganze schön
angebraten ist können wir einmal wenden
ich bin heute übrigens selbst nicht
streng genommen am Tasten aber ich habe
extra nur gefrühstückt und wer sonst
nichts essen damit ich mich so ein
bisschen dafür sensibilisieren kann so
wie schmeckt das Ganze so auf so einem
sehr hungrigen Magen oh ich find ich
habe wirklich das Gefühl das wird
richtig hart später wenn alles
angebraten ist wurden jetzt raus
Sicherheitsabstand mit T-Shirt wird
gewartet vor allen Dingen der Topf und
du sagte den lösen wir jetzt aus mit
Schalotten Knoblauch Sellerie Möhren und
ein bisschen Olivenöl fleißig umrühren
Tomatenmark dran und scharfes Paprika
Pulver einmal kräftig kümmertifizieren
und ablassen
zack kann man natürlich auch mit
Weißwein Rotwein Rotwein natürlich schön
zu lang aber restliche Brühe dazu jetzt
haben wir noch ein paar Zutaten die wir
hinzugeben Rosinen liebt man nicht aber
ich sage euch ehrlich wenn ich die ganze
Zeit in dieser Brühe köcheln diesen
herzhaften Geschmack aufnehmen ist das
was ganz anderes Kreuz Kümmel für diesen
orientalischen Kick und Tomate sowie
Thymian merkst du was der Kreuzkümmel
macht wie du das brauchst richtig krank
jetzt kommt das Lamm wieder dazu die
Farben wieder ne das ist wirklich das
schönste so Bräter Gerichte sind
wirklich das schönste was man seinen
Augen zeigen kann jetzt mit Wasser
auffüllen bis alles bedeckt ist right
Deckel drauf Backofen ist vorgeheizt 140
Grad und jetzt gehen wir dem alle Zeit
der Welt mindestens einhalb Stunden eine
weitere Beilage sind diese Auberginen
die wir schön dick geschnitten haben und
jetzt einmal mit dem Ofen durchrösten
davor aber ordentlich salzen zieht alles
raus was wir nicht mit drin haben wollen
ich habe Bitterstoffe werden auch
entzogen am besten auf so einem
gitterding damit das von oben und
bestimmten Luft ziehen kann warten wir
kurz und dann Tupfen wir das mit C war
guckt Euch das einmal bitte an es hat
wirklich richtig richtig gut
funktioniert Wasser wurde gezogen das
wollen wir alles nicht drin haben
geschmacklich deshalb Tupfen wir einmal
ab dann stellen wir jetzt einmal in
unseren Ofen einfach dazu und spätestens
jetzt seht ihr wir haben einiges an
Zutaten wir hier stehen einen frischen
Topf wir machen ein echtes Fest mal ich
meine wenn man nur einmal am Tag ist
dann wollen wir auch alles mitnehmen die
klassische Datteln bevor Speise
Hauptspeise und das Süßes für hinterher
wir machen jetzt eine Linsensuppe
türkischer Style also mehr Schimmer
kennt man das ganze auch hier drüben
habe ich geschnittene Karotten Zwiebeln
Kartoffeln bisschen Knoblauch Ingwer
Topf heiß machen und ein guter Stich
Butter hinein dieses Rezept ist angelegt
das von Gülcan erinnert euch die
türkische Oma die uns empfangen hat und
uns gezeigt hat wie sie kocht einiges
mitgenommen vor allem wie unglaublich
gut diese Mädchen geschmeckt hat
übrigens nicht dieses genau Gericht
sondern das heißt einfach links auf
türkisch wenn die Butter gebräunt ist
kommt das Gemüse dazu ich fange mal an
mit dem Kartoffeln und noch die Zwiebeln
die Möhren
und das beste alles was wir heute kochen
mit Köpfchen können wir natürlich dann
ganz entspannt bei Markt entweder fertig
kochen aufwärmen und dann perfekt
getimed servieren jetzt gehen wir
Tomatenmark dazu paprika-markt bzw dass
man ein bisschen Knoblauch und so dabei
Nana Minze Kreuzkümmel und natürlich wir
kochen für Mark Chili jetzt noch unsere
roten Linsen
wunderschönen Farben vor Knoblauch und
ein bisschen geriebener Ingwer den
Knoblauch lass sie einfach ganz die
anderen Sachen habe ich gleichmäßig grob
geschnitten einmal durchführen dazu zu
sagen und wir füllen mit Wasser auf
hier geht es das alles bedeckt ist mit
den Deckel drauf und lassen das Ganze
einfach für 20 Minuten kochen auch
unsere Beilage ist was ganz besonderes
ich habe hier Safran in heißem Wasser
schon mal aufgelöst aromatisiert aber
zunächst gebe ich ein bisschen
Butterschmalz in unseren Reiskocher den
schmelzt sich da denn wir wollen jetzt
diesen persischen Kreis machen der
Butterschmalz ist geschmolzen ich
schätze jetzt Safran mit Wasser dazu wir
gucken das alles mit rauskommt ist dass
sie alles komplett aus jetzt unser Reis
machen eine ordentliche Portion 400
Gramm ist natürlich gewaschen und ich
Wasser drauf jetzt eine Prise Salz aber
ein bisschen durchrühren die Farbe ist
jetzt schon geil ne zumachen crispy
eineinhalb Stunden ich glaube jetzt
heißt es nur noch warten bis der Ofen
fertig ist bis der Reis fertig ist die
Suppe dürfte jetzt sogar schon fertig
gekocht sein wir ziehen die dann einmal
frisch auf mit dem Pürierstab hier ist
unsere Arbeit jetzt erledigt ab geht's
zum Markt nach Düsseldorf
[Musik]
ich bin ich bin ich bin ich
und jetzt aktuell wenn du so fragst was
so das nächste Hype Produkt was du jetzt
auf einmal jeder hat also Mickey Sascha
Nico auch Wohnzimmer
Kopf ins Jahr und der wo kann man den
kaufen
auf.com was ist dein intensivster Luft
von der von der Silage
das ist schon in der gesamten Industrie
quasi der stärkste Pullover waschen und
das wird halt noch da sein mach mal
[Gelächter]
in die Küche gehen ich zeig dir noch
einen Stinker damit wir auch alles
abgelegt haben
nö aber ich würde sagen
das ist der Markus Rühl doch
wirklich der wirkt auf jeden Fall ne
jetzt musst du auf jeden Fall schmecken
deshalb gehen wir in die Küche machen
das Ganze fertig und lassen uns
schmecken hoffentlich 15 Minuten bis
Sonnenuntergang wir sind in der Küche
angekommen so sieht das hier aus und
kann auf jeden Fall super arbeiten hier
ich habe eigentlich alles schon fertig
dabei einmal hier unseren Safranreis
dann habe ich vorbereitet ein paar
Datteln weil traditionell bricht man ja
fast mit einer Dattel Baklava ist bisher
noch eine schöne pide die wir gleich zu
unserer Linsensuppe machen werden die
steht hier mache ich einfach mal warm
dann pürieren wir die durch und passen
noch ein bisschen an mit Wasser und
unsere Lammschulter ist wirklich
wunderschön geworden da freue ich mich
sehr darauf ich mache noch einen
schnellen Minions oder das habe ich so
ein fettigen griechischen noch dabei wir
haben noch genau 15 Minuten
einfach ein paar Blätter unsere
Linsensuppe toppen wir dann auch noch
mit ein bisschen Petersilie wenn es ein
bisschen aktivieren Minze rein Salz
Pfeffer noch dran euch riecht durch
diese ätherischen Öle entweder von der
Minze oder von meinem Pulli ah ich weiß
nicht genau schreib mir uns den Mix ab
und ziehen das hier einmal durch wir
haben eine wunderschöne sämige
Konsistenz wir wollen das ganze aber ein
bisschen flüssiger bekommen ich habe mir
einfach ein bisschen Wasser
ein bisschen was in unsere Suppe hinein
die habe ich noch eine pide die gebe ich
jetzt einfach kurz in den Ofen 5 Minuten
wieder schön warm und knusprig ist wir
bringen jetzt die Suppe auf die perfekte
Konsistenz und dann servieren wird
noch ein paar Minuten ne das ist
natürlich jetzt die letzten Minuten
ich bin richtig bereit bist du jeden so
ganz Tradition ja wir fangen jetzt an
weil mit einer
gibt aber auch große Unterschiede bei
Datteln wahrscheinlich oder schöne Grüße
an den DR Schein wir waren zusammen in
meckern und normalerweise also viele
Leute bevorzugen diese großen Datteln er
hat mir immer gesagt die guten Datteln
also das ist nur für die Esel also nicht
für die Esel als Person sondern wirklich
ein Esel sondern in Mekka bekommt man
immer diese ganz kleinen also so sehen
die aus die haben wir pflaumenfasten und
hör mal da sind wie Steine also die
haben wir mitgebracht
jetzt komme ich bring Essen mit und du
hast das bessere essen darf
[Musik]
getrocknete Pflaumen ein bisschen härter
ne also wirklich muss ich sagen die
werden auch nicht schlecht und so sehr
lecker eigentlich nicht zurück wer du
hast auch an die Zitrone gedacht das
schon mal sehr gut von der Suppe her wie
war es so für Dich sehr sehr entspannte
Gerichte okay bei allen so die Zeit für
uns gearbeitet hat uns ganz entspannt
gemacht und jetzt hoffe ich dass dir
schmeckt
okay eigenes Rezept oder woher ist das
nee das ist ein bisschen Kikis kitchen
und ein bisschen türkische Oma die für
mich gekocht hat okay alles zusammen
geworfen ja aber lassen wir uns erstmal
schmecken wir machen das ganz ähnlich
wie bei PK das kennst ja Essen auf und
dann kannst du noch ein zwei Worte dazu
verlieren aber du sollst vor allem auch
ungestört genießen können ja ich habe
zwei Teller gegessen ich bin absolut
begeistert und bin halt nächster Gang
was sie für Dich besser aus beide sehen
gut aus hier ist fettiger von mir ist
sowas von Sport machen ja
boah ich muss sagen hier der Reis der
sieht ja sehr wie gezeichnet ne ich
würde sagen du kannst ja gerne ein
bisschen was vom Reis nehmen ich hole
noch was zum Aufgeben dann bisschen Minz
Joghurt ja noch mal ein bisschen Zitrone
und dann lassen wir uns schmecken und
natürlich wichtig für dich hier ne ja
das darf man nicht vergessen sagen wir
im Ofen
Auberginen jetzt mal eine Frage was ist
denn so aktuell so dein was ist du oder
was kochst du so am liebsten was du dein
Lieblingsgericht wo Du gerade aktuell
sagst das hat mich richtig überzeugt
also das feiere ich aktuell es ist
gerade zum Fitness Film bin ja das wird
ja keine Emotionen wecken Instagram
Pudding mit Proteinpulver und gefrorenen
Himbeeren z.B oder aber auch ähm low
carry Baby mit pastrami Spiegelei okay
mag ich auch sehr gerne gut dann lass
Dir schmecken die ersten Reaktionen
können wir ja schon mal mitnehmen okay
jetzt so so guck dir das mal an das ist
ja ein Hauch von von nichts weil ich bin
auch auf den reiste gespannt ne also ich
meine was das denn hier los erstmal in
Ruhe auf was sagst du das war ein sehr
leckeres Essen das freut mich also das
muss ich sagen das Schmorgericht war top
der Reis war top nicht zu üppig wenn man
den ganzen Tag nicht gegessen hat oder
genau richtig ich sag mal so ich bin
schon genau guck mal
also was soll ich dir sagen ja der Knopf
hier der der macht den ganzen Job von
uns allen
gut
ich habe noch eine Kleinigkeit
vorbereitet es gibt einen kleinen Tee
dazu ein Baklava und dann schießt du
genau diesen Knopf
wie lange hast du denn dafür gebraucht
jetzt sag mal erstmal eine Blätterteig
machen ich hoffe du hattest einen
angenehmes Abendessen sehr sehr schön
ich habe im Prinzip mir einfach durch
meinen Kochen mir ein Abendessen mit dir
erkauft
ich hatte sehr viel Spaß viel vielen
Dank für das Kochen und bis jederzeit
herzlich eingeladen ich komme gerne
wieder vielen lieben Dank ich muss sagen
experience kulinarisch super lecker
falls heute Bayram ist wenn ihr das
sieht dann ein schönes Fest euch allen
und bis zum nächsten Video ciao